[Musique]
aujourd'hui nombreux sont les militants
qui ont décidé de dénoncer la chasse et
les pratiques jugées non essentielles
qui met à mal l'intégrité physique des
animaux et une nouvelle affaire de cette
chasse à courre a fait polémique c'est
dans l'oise que cette traque acharnée
d'un cerf durant des heures a fait
parler filmé par des passants sous le
choc on peut découvrir sur les images
des chasseurs traqué sans relâche
l'animal qui effrayées épuisé essaye
d'échapper à la mort une chasse en
pleine ville qui au delà de la violence
qu'elle impose aux riverains et de leur
mise en danger a perturbé durant de
longues heures le trafic aux abords de
la gare de chantilly ainsi que celui des
trains contraint d'être immobilisé la
maire de la ville isabelle mouilleseaux
vièze a vivement réagi à ce dérapage se
sert aux abois poursuivi dans un milieu
hostile a mis en danger la sécurité des
piétons
de son côté la sncf a décidé de porter
plainte contre x alors dérapages lors
d'une chasse à courre faut-il arrêter
cette pratique ce soir mathieu payet
amateurs de chasse à courre était avec
nous pour défendre sa passion faut-il
arrêter la chasse à courre quoiqu'à
payet braqueur un acteur de chasse est
avec nous merci en tout cas d'être là
bonsoir alors c'est vrai qu'un a
beaucoup qui vont être contrepoint ce
soir la mairie de chantilly
la maire de chantilly isabelle isabelle
et la mère qui est très sympa qui avait
ressenti
elle a déploré un événement
inqualifiable qui a mis en danger des
habitants se sert aux abois poursuivi
dans un milieu hostile a mis en danger
la sécurité des piétons auraient pu
générer des accidents routiers a
perturbé la circulation recul à sion
ferroviaire engendrant des retards
importants pour les cantiliens merci en
tout cas à la maire de chantilly alors
faut-il arrêter cette pratique alors
raymond on a un nom alors vas pas bravo
des devenu bercy mathieu raymond je ne
comprends pas en fait je ne prends pas
alors déjà moi je suis contre la corrida
lors on va me dire c'est la culture
c'est comme ça je comprends pas d'être
un taureau et de s'acharner sur un
taureau jeunes et chasseurs hockey parce
qu'on me dit qu'il faut qu'ils chassent
pas ce qu'on doit manger d'aller en etc
il faut chasser et c'est pour les
animaux pour pas que j'en ai partout et
c'est la prolifération mais vous votre
délire je ne comprends pas vous envoie l
engager plein de chiens en fait c'est ce
que je regardais avec le plein de chiens
depuis françois 1er ça fait ça depuis
1500 les années 1500 vous êtes avec
plein de chiens un clairon dette sur des
chevaux et vous épuisez l'animal c'est
ce que j'ai compris moi je suis
animal c'est un truc dont je vous prends
le temps on peut partir de chez soi est
d'abord allé je monte sur un cheval je
vais arriver turan a expliqué c'est ce
que je ressens presque être fait j'aime
bien mais je comprends pas pour comment
alors tu vas nous et susana vera bien de
chasse à courre à mathieu depuis la 20
ans vous pratiquer cette discipline
depuis que je suis tout petit parce que
c'est de faire en 6 une tradition
familiale le plus haut du côté de ma mè
un meilleur jeu à cheval depuis déjà une
dizaine d'années mais alors c'est quoi
c'est quoi le principe alors le principe
qu'on rappelle le principe
ouais le principe à sa cause que c'est
vrai mais en fait c'est méconnu bien on
avait un vrai problème là dessus c'est
que la chasse à courre est méconnu ces
images sont quasiment les seuls qu'on
voit donc forcément quand on connaît pas
on se dit c'est affreux c'est horrible
c'est dégueulasse comment ils peuvent
faire ça maintenant on est quand même
dix mille cotisants en france à chasser
à coups récents mille suiveurs je pense
que l'on se dit bien que si à cent mille
personnes qui aiment cette pratique
c'est que ça doit pas être ça en fait la
chasse à courre donc c'est une chasse
qui accueille historique
évidemment qui est la chasse qui est la
plus naturelle qui soit c'est à dire que
le principe fondamental c'est que on va
stimuler des animaux sauvages par des
chiens
donc c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans départ des loups dans des forêts où
il ya encore des loups il y en a plus
quasiment plus en france ils commencent
à revenir un petit peu mais c'est une
chasse qui consiste vraiment l'homme à
rester en dehors de cette chasse est de
confronter des animaux sauvages entre
eux les chiens nos chiens sont pas des
chiens appartement c'est les chiens avec
des chiens qui chasse comme tous les
réflexes quand tous les chiens normaux
qui doivent aimer la chasse et on va
confronter en fait des proies que sont
ces grands herbivores qui n'ont plus de
prédateurs aujourd'hui dans l'art dans
la dans les forêts françaises à ces
chiens là donc nous on encadre ce
travail là et en fait on va s'intéresser
on va analyser nos chiens donc les
chiens on les connaît alors on avance
chasse avec une trentaine de chiens ce
qui est intéressant c'est tous les
connaître connaître leur caractère quand
mais quelles sont leurs quelles sont
leurs qualités leurs défauts shot ces
images là alors ces images là elle me
choque moins que celle qu'on avait c'est
en fait il s'est déjà fait déplacer
c'est choquant parce que on voit
en fait on voit du sauvage au milieu la
civilisation c'est ça qui me perturbe
après le cerf il n'est pas blessé il est
pas mort il est fatigué comme un cirque
a couru voulais tu voulais tuer
maintenant fait ce alors si c'est la
banalité de notre schaaf voulait tuer à
la fin j'assume blanchissent plus tôt
explique de couteau il ya une mise à
mort la finalité de la chasse
alors faut savoir qu'en france il ya 400
équipages 120 chasse le lièvre un peu
moins de sangliers chevreuils et se
montre en deux sets le sert donc quand
on parle de chasse à courre faut parler
de chasse au lièvre en priorité à la fin
pour les petites baies ce qu'on appelle
la petite vénerie c'est à dire les
lièvres et lapins les renards sont les
chiens qui coiffe l'animal chevreuils et
c'est aussi ça donc c'est chaque fois
fin animal comme un lion pourrait
coiffer une antilope le sanglier le cerf
peuvent obtenir ce qu'on appelle les à
boisleux ferme pour les sangliers et
faire face aux chiens plusieurs cas de
figures parfois les chiens couche de
même leur animal ce qui est je dirais la
prédation la plus naturelle qui soit
quand on loue attrape un mouton fins et
c'est naturel et si dans et sinon là
l'homme intervient donc l'homme
intervient il peut intervenir de deux
manières
la première c'est à l'armé à feu c'est
ce qu'on privilégie de plus en plus
parce que voilà quand on est à la
ressemblance j'ai un jeu aussi alors à
l'armé blanche ça arrive aux poteaux oui
au couteau pourquoi ont choisi l'armé
blanche ont choisi l'armé blanche il ya
une question de mois je trouve que de
prélever un animal de prélever une vie
en appuyant sur une détente
il ya un côté où on garde ses distances
si on prend pas de risques parce que ce
que je dans l'armé blanche que je trouve
qui est respectable quand même c'est con
mais aussi un peu sa vie en danger parce
que prévu
wissant il ya quand même il faut savoir
c'est que on a aucun plaisir à tuer
l'animal alors nous attendre alors vous
donner une idée on tue un animal sur
quatre chats c'est là où je chasse mais
plutôt à une chasse sur 7,8 si on avait
plaisir à tuer les animaux pour huit
sorties toute la journée imagine bien
que la veille on prépare les chiens on
prépare les chevaux notre matériel
le matin on est au bois pour observer
les animaux l'été on va au bois pour
observer les animaux on chasse pas tout
ça si la finalité c'est de la mort d'un
animal et le plaisir de faire souffrir
un animal on passerait pas autant de
points faire ça bernard montiel op non
moi je sais bien que c'était l'époque de
la renaissance était un art de vivre
mais c'est fini il a cédé temps passe et
tout ça je trouve ça scandaleux monstre
choquant et en avait sérieusement par
les génois ça suffit ça et qu'on termine
en termes il s'appelle la curée c'est la
mise à mort systématique non c'est pas
écrit martin et non la curie n'est pas
la mort non la curée c'est quand on
donne l'animal à montjaux chien
retraçons la chasse c'est horrible c'est
moi c'est là le théorie moi ce que
j'aime ce que j'aime dans la chasse à
courre et enfin c'est bien de mener ce
que j'aime souvent on nous hurle dessus
on aime on n'aime pas ce qu'on aime
année correcte on vous parle d'accord
moi je suis déjà je suis passionnée
d'équitation
notre cheval de bataille à la suède je
sais pas si je suis un passionné chien
il ya une chose moi qui me plaît c'est
c'est que c'est une chasse qui reste en
dehors de toute technologie c'est à dire
que je trouve qu'on manque aujourd'hui
de deux d'immersion dans la nature à les
voir un zoo c'est pas quelque chose qui
me plaît ça ne fait pas qu'y fait ouais
mais la mise à mort moi j'adore le
cheval je comprends qu'on a envie de se
balader en équipe qu'on problèmes qu'on
puisse aller se balader avec des chiens
on pourrait faire la même chose sans
pour autant avoir une cible et en plus
excusez moi c'est l'année mais il est
fatigué
et puis certains d'ailleurs font des
crises cardiaques il meurt de france est
épouvantable ils sont finis au couteau
et s'est quand même
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit c'est quand
même plus chic paraît-il de finir au
couteau que que au fusil il ya une
souffrance que semblait dire oui
et je dis pas que c'est plus joli nom
mais c'est plus c'est qu'on est
courageux les plus courageux voilà
artistique vous dire si je n'aime pas
c'est plus respectueuse vis-à-vis de
l'animal m'avait demandé n'imaginais pas
que je suis un mort à l'armé blanche est
moins rapide des plus gores qu'une
hanine tucson mise à mort aux armes à
feu mais j'peux vous pouvez faire la
même c'est ça c'est la même chose et
respecter les travaux les abattoirs il
sait faire la même chose en respectant
les traditions vous avez dit le beau
costume prendre les chiens sans pour
autant aller massacrer un insert après
je comprends qu'il ait 100 du trophée
parce que moi quand je suis c'est pas du
hameau refi vous aimez le cheval comme
moi en plus dans ce genre de chasse
souvent souvent blessé chevaux toujours
blessé a dû souvent aussi une foire les
images ça s'il vous plaît pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent à 20h49 et on en passe
[Musique]
le ser j'hallucine kifani qu'est-ce qui
se passe alors je suis d'accord
pardon monsieur mais c'est de la
barbarie c'est cruel c'est un être
vivant qu'ils soient domestiques ou
qu'ils soient sauvages c'est cruel
vous aimez les chiens et si on faisait
pareil avec vos chiens ont les épuise
ont leurs cours après ils sont là ils se
couchent sur la voie ferrée les pauvres
et là on tue vos chiens à coups de
couteau parce que ces nobles et parce
que ça c'est une pratique a été abolie
vous vous rendez compte on parle au
danemark et en norvège
au xviiie siècle ça a été aboli en
allemagne en 1934 il a été aboli en
belgique ça a été abolie dans plusieurs
pays pourquoi pas chez nous vous rendez
compte il ya eu des incidents sur des
routes nationales parce qu'il ya eu
d'émeutes ont ils traversé via insère
dans un champ qu'a fini en étant
dévorées par des chiens par vos chiens
et vous trouvez que c'est pas barbare
vous trouvez que ce n'est pas cruel on
parle d'un être vivant
si on faisait ça à vos chevaux et si on
faisait ça à vos chiens vous trouvez ça
normal qu'on termine l'opticien l'armé
blanche alors moi je veux dire s'il vous
plaît on l'est on laisse répondre oui
mais on laisse répondre mathieu d'il ya
une approche de la nature qu'on peut
avoir et qui peut être différente sur
moi quand je vois une antilope se faire
chasser par marion et se faire prendre
par à lyon je peux me dire pauvre
antilopes je peux aussi me dire pour
petit lionceau
si la neige c'est la loi de la jungle
mais c'est naturel et là quelle est la
loi de la nature avec les prédateurs en
fait on a je vais vous dire on a
aujourd'hui un vrai problème c'est que
dans nos forêts françaises on a fait
disparaître les deux principaux
prédateurs qui étaient les loups les
ours
d'accord ça c'est ce qui permettait la
régulation de ces grands prédateurs et
pas seulement ça permettait aux choses
ça permettait de stimuler leur haine
pure sous leur aspect sauvage en fait
aujourd'hui la chasse à tir
effectivement un aspect de régulation
qui est nécessaire les équilibres
naturels le le monde c'est évident que
la chasse est nécessaire il ya des
choses qui doivent être améliorés on est
bien d'accord
il ya beaucoup de choses qui s'améliore
la chasse à courre elle un avantage
considérable c'est que l stimulus
sauvage et elle fait faire à des animaux
chassés déployer des qualités de russes
de vitesse d'intelligence que seule la
chasse permet de faire donc vous savez
on fait ça maintient cette année pour le
maintien
radi intéressant mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
des exemples au parc de chambord par
exemple ils ont arrêté à chasse à courre
en 47 j'ai pas si vous avez eu
l'occasion déjà d'aller voir vous avez
des serres qui font 200 kg qui sont
particulièrement gras vous avez des
serres qui sont dans les prairies à
brouter à 14 heures d'après midi vous
avez une saison du bram où les serbes à
aller au bout de cinq minutes ils ont
une langue qui est pendu comme ça bien
il ya un constat mais la hausse est la
langue pendue comme ça oui mais après
quatre heures de chasse alors que
toucher parce que c'est isabelle après
les pro chasse vont dire que la chasse a
sert au prélèvement hockey dans le
canton de genève depuis 1970 il ya plus
de chasse et il n'y a aucun souci avec
les animaux n'y a pas de débordements
donc ça c'est pour la chasse et foulards
dont je peux finir merci
donc ça c'est que pour la chasse
maintenant je vais parler de la chasse à
courre la chasse à courre c'est 1%
la chasse nationale donc on parle même
pas de prélèvement c'est pas du
prélèvement c'est pour se faire plaisir
des gens qui ont de l'argent vont aller
vont choisir un seul animal et vont leur
courir après pendant toute la journée et
au bout d'un moment on sait bien on fait
tous du footing ici autour de la table
quand on n'en peut plus on n'en peut
plus l'animal va s'arrêter et là il va
être accueilli par des gens par des
chiens qui m'ont qui vont le bouffer de
dand sous l'animal va se coucher et là
vous allez venir fièrement vous avez
posé un petit billet et vous allez
l'égorger avant de le regarder encore
une dernière fois je suis désolé moi
c'est que ce qui me touche beaucoup
je suis fille de petite fille de
chasseurs et mon grand père c'était la
personne que j'aimais le plus au monde
et à chaque fois qu'ils partaient à la
chasse je lui demandais de pâtir et pour
moi parfois il le faisait parfois il le
faisait pas mais je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui en 2021 en plus vous êtes
un jeune je n'ose même pas vous regarder
je suis désolé ça me je trouve que les
jeunes puissent encore soutenir ça moi
ça me sam des kuchis désolé il n'y a pas
le droit que sont les dates des finales
de voix sur les réseaux sociaux qui sont
en pleurs qui travaillent là après avoir
vu dans la vie magescas serra et
delphine votre témoignage chili un
talisman fait juste pour revenir sur le
combat incroyable témoignage de da sais
pas si je peux me permettre de remettre
sur l'histoire du concours de genève
effectivement la chaîne rai avait perdu
dans ce canton
comment vois tu veux ça on va rentrer
dans les détails la série et isabelle
moi j'ai vu une chasse à courre pardon
alors je suis d'accord avec vous sur la
régulation c'est fait 70 conneries il
aurait des prédateurs ça n'enlève rien
en fait effectivement que c'est une
chasse il est east que l'animal est
totalement affolée par les bruits que
les chiens sont rendus fous par
l'isolation parce qu'ils sortent aussi
eu pour la chasse le ressort est pas
terriblement viable parce qu'ils sont
bien soignés dans six villes dans ce but
là tous les bras tous les laisser faire
tout ça alors c'est qu'on chasse il est
brouillé avec des brakni avec des
satellites ils font pas des chiens de
chasse à courre moi j'ai vu des chiens
se briser le insert se brisaient les
pattes devant moi c'est bien pour un
reportage y étaient ses thèmes et
affreux alors d'abord toutes les cuves
les yeux littéralement révulsait qui
sortaient de leurs mythes et puis le
pelage évidemment complètement moi tu es
tout et l'animal et s est brisé les
pattes en tombant un espèce de pouvoir
ce que pensent les champions ses
téléspectateurs à la question dérapages
lors d'une chasse à courre faut-il
arrêter cette pratique oui à 84% à peine
non à 16 % serait justement la venue de
guillaume genton qui a dit non je vous
souhaite juste un peu il peut qu rythme
les images me choque évidemment mais les
chiens on dit que c'est terrible des
chiens mangent dessert les chiens moi
j'ai trois chiens et les chats il mange
des croquettes ya du poulet dans les
pluies sont tortueux on s'indigne de la
souffrance animale il ya une majorité de
gens aujourd'hui qu'ils mangent de la
viande on est tous coupables entre
guillemets de souffrance animale dans
ces cas les voleurs comme delphine il
faut ne pas manger de viande et ça c'est
un vrai climat apaisé mais tout le monde
s'accorde en ce moment justement pour ce
qu'ils mangent de la non parce qu'il y
en a qui aiment ça à ce que la fin de
vie des animaux soit d'un fai dans un
extrait de la souffrance arrêt devient
n'importe quoi
84 % disent qu'il faut arrêter en tout
cas merci mathieu d'être venu nous
expliquer ce état sicura le dollar parce
que faut pas c'est vrai que vous étiez
son lait venus vous êtes les bienvenus
hamon journée au monté à shawn a in your
browser
j'ai eu plein merci castaldi merci en
tout cas mathieu d'être venu recevoir
courage ou de votre part